les régions ultrapéritériques sont des
postes avancés de l'Union européenne sur
les trois océans
[Musique]
la situation économique des rupes est
fort préoccupante parce que les rupes
sont très éloignées du centre de
l'Europe sont dans des situations
environnementales et géographiques
parfois très compliquées et les marchés
économiques sont restreints doux un fort
taux de chômage et des problèmes sociaux
que tout cela génère les régions
ultrapéritériques sont des postes
avancés de l'Union européenne sur les
trois océans
[Musique]
l'Union européenne peut favoriser le
développement économique d'abord par les
aides qu'elle apporte il faut
effectivement permettre à ces régions
d'avoir un développement économique
harmonieux en permettant d'acquérir des
infrastructures pérennes de rendre ces
territoires plus accessibles donc une
meilleure connectivité avec le monde et
singulièrement avec l'Europe en
permettant aux jeunes de pouvoir trouver
les formations sur place pour ne pas
avoir à émigrer enfin l'Europe peut
aussi permettre aux régions ultra
périphériques de se sentir pleinement
européen et non des citoyens de souzones
la mesure phare zone franche sociale qui
exonérerait de charges salariale et de
charge patronales les 90% de petites
micro-entreprises que nous avons avec un
véritable partenariat avec les
entreprises pour qu'ils embauchent
davantage et aider à la formation
merci l'Europe de soutenir
financièrement culturellement les
régions ultra périphériques
[Musique]